hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to dark wood we
are coming back from a fruitful
adventure in the village where we help
the wolf find
the love of his life maybe i'm gonna
assume that because i've got nothing
left to assume
all right so there's got to be something
else over here to the left that i can
quickly grab
maybe another camp that i can disturb
the piece of
and then take the supplies of or maybe a
bear trap or something
i wished i had a rock do i have a rock
i don't have a rock i never that's an
egg i don't have a rock
i bet if i throw a rock at that it'll
either blow up
or not blow up or maybe i'm just an
idiot and it wouldn't do either
logs i have not gotten these logs a
stone i can try my tactic
all right i'm guessing that that stone
throwing idea
was stupid and i'm dumb uh
nail i have so many nails do i need more
nails
always probably probably always man it's
only logs it's not planks did i come
through here
already no where am i i'm in the log
camp
of course there's got to be some more to
the bottom left i've still got time
oh do i have enough
lock picks uh yeah you know what why not
cool that'll do that's not bad
oh found the cottage uh didn't know that
i
didn't have this found um
okay it's a destroyed generator well i
just put away the gas
um destroyed how oh well
the woods have uh consumed it
i see stuff in there how do you how
would you get it
oh there's a path around aha oh i gotta
hurry
i don't have much room in my inventory
so i don't know why i'm even bothering
with this but just in case there's
something in there
just in case there's something good you
never know
hello bam corpse
chest key interesting interesting
interesting uh you can have an egg i'll
trade you in oh
i forgot that uh
uh i'll eat it oh i need a key
but i got a key to the to the chest
i got the chest key hello
just key oh it's oh wait what
wait now it's hey hey hey whoa whoa whoa
hey hey
whoa hey stop get stop it
i'm trying oh my god hey hey hey hey
back up back up back up back up
listen i don't want to do this all right
you're gonna get it okay that's that was
a warning
you still coming for me lady listen man
sir sorry
you had that coming you you did that to
yourself
i gave you so much warning and room to
back off i was out of your house
uh you came after me at that point it
was your fault
geez also don't spook me like that also
i gotta go
like now like yesterday
toolbox i don't need another toolbox but
it's good money i guess
yeah okay i gotta go i gotta go do i
have my ability
third eye what does this even mean oh
that's what that means oh god well
that's really handy
that would have been perfect for the
well exploration that i didn't know that
i
could do this for and i kind of forgot
about my abilities because i think i'm
on my own
man really being able to see oh yeah
unlocked my third eye sooner my chakras
probably gaining all these special
abilities is mutating me horribly and
it's gonna leave me uh
worse for wear oh it's crazy being able
to see everything well that was very
helpful thank you
okay we're good we're good turn on
hey that used a lot of gas last night
what is that about
i i filled that full and it's half
that's all right okay and then
i've got this to cook
not that i'm never going to get to 2400
jeez those five
either they're gonna throw something
completely different at me soon or
that's just a whole hell of a lot
military flashlight let's see what this
thing
does and then go from there
oh okay well the battery goes down quick
never mind it's probably something that
the nine volts actually i can replace
the battery in and it's probably a
bigger light
so this you know it's all good but for
now i'll just rely on
ye old torch okay night has begun
all right try it try it bud try it bud
try it bud look you're about to get a
bad surprise
tomorrow morning i'm definitely going to
move the other light in here just
because i don't know why
come here come here come here where are
you oh god i hate that i can't see you
was that the second one yeah it was okay
come on
ow come on you oh my god no you do not
where are you oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god i can't
[ __ ] see you go oh my god because of
the
it's oh my [ __ ] god
oh my god oh my god
oh my god there's got to be like a some
long-term punishment to that but i've
already died once i
didn't realize that if i had the door
there oh my god
uh all right i'll be back i gotta push
the light
and also why was the freaking shovel so
goddamn
slow it was like i was slower than usual
on swinging the shovel i don't know
that was stupid and i hated it what a
day a friend
what a day huh i've had a day let me
tell you
all right you are right there by my
bench so i can see
because that's important and you're
right there
perfect i'm probably not even going to
be here another night because i
intend to go beyond i'm gonna go try to
get across the bridge today
i wasn't even gonna be here wasn't even
gonna stay
all right hi hey how are you i've got
nothing new to show you
you're so nice i love you and everything
about you
you're the best so what i need is
um to sell all the crap that i have so
far
wait hang on i just had a thought
blueprint battery
something something something real i
have these items
what if i give them to him i have some
of these items i don't have everything
but i've got some of them
fan belt battery all these things that
are basically useless
because they don't have anything but
they might be useful to that person
whoever they are so i got to keep that
in mind so i'm going to carry them with
me
the stones i'm i just i
don't care toolbox i'm going to sell
that to this guy
right now i'm going to get the delivery
guy to get the rest of this crap
i'm gonna i need the bell like i have to
bring the bell if i'm gonna use the bell
two stacks of wood two stacks of nails
that's fair pistol ammo
i'm probably gonna find gas there
knowing these hideouts i'm going to find
gas but this has to be like a dedicated
journey
to the hideout first and foremost above
anything because if i don't
i will die and a bottle of booze i have
to have a bottle of booze i almost
forgot about that i have to have the
booze
to get him to do the thing i guess just
in case
i need matches but i don't think i will
you need one match to light it
like the the oven for the gas all right
that should be
plenty i'll find gas on the way i'll
bring gas
just in case just in case i have no idea
what i'm gonna find
but just in case okay all right sig
i don't know why i moved these i am
journeying oh why did i bother i don't
know i why did i do anything
i i have no idea i don't know anymore i
i just don't understand myself
but got everything i need i'm gonna head
straight over to pedrick's
i'm gonna give him what i have if he'll
take it and if he doesn't take it i'll
drop it on his floor or something i
don't know but i'm gonna make my way
this is now the journey to the other
safe house
that's what this is and if i make it
great if i don't well then i'm screwed
aren't i
honestly like i thought this game was
going to be a hardcore game where
when you die you die and then it's game
over
thank goodness it's not because i'm not
nearly skilled enough especially on my
first run through
to try to do that but you know you know
good it's a good thing
whoa okay oh my goodness
oh all right you mind if i swoop in here
uh booze i like booze rags good
corpse okay just corpse not touchable
great whoa hey bud
and they're wandering all over the woods
patrick oh god oh god oh my god
oh my god
i just wandered into that that's fine is
this pietrick yeah pietro
hey patrick so i think with the dogs
just i gotta always be sidestepping i
don't have to worry about trying to
dodge
specifically it's just like sidewinding
because they'll they'll always lunge and
they're always faster than me
hello hi hi pio trick
i've got a battery
a hybrid rocket engine wow this will fit
perfectly in my rocket
have you seen it have you seen my rocket
it's almost as pretty as gagarin's
well almost i just need to find some
parts and it will be completely ready
would you bring them to me the other
parts i would then fly to space in the
moon and mars and jupiter into the sun
i mean i would land at night the boy
suddenly looks in my eyes
look for an old tractors you'll find the
missing pieces for my rockets in them
sure okay fan belt hold door frame
stabilizer only two more to go
trajectory guidance system i only need
one more part
all right cool i haven't gotten it yet i
might have seen it and then ignorantly
didn't pick it up
that is always a possibility but you
know i'm trying my best
cable i need that for the pig farm
all right i don't know what the last
item would be but maybe um
maybe this might help me on my way
either way it's it's good because
i i guess i wasn't as done with this
area as i thought i was
okay thanks pia trick i'll be back if i
see the last piece i don't know though
maybe in the old woods apparently some
tells me about the old woods
is not going to be super fun to be in
some tells me maybe the old woods are
going to be
where the woods have grown the worst i
don't want to see this big pig
i said something about a big pig and i
don't know if i want that
oh man really noticing these bear traps
finally
they're probably all over the place i'm
probably just incredibly lucky
that that's all i imagine is like i'm
just outlandishly lucky
that i have not slammed my tootsies
into every bear trap in the area okay
there's something here
i can bind these together all right
i did it i did that anyway pig heads
hello lever i need to turn on the power
to use the lever okay so i have to turn
on the power
so i got to get in this place
somehow not that way
oh there's something snuffling around in
there oh it's huge
all right weird uh i'm not 100 sure
how to get in here uh looks like my
dreams of maybe the second hideout are
dying around me how do you get in here
jeez oh how do you get in there
it's probably around the bottom left i
probably have done it before and i'm
just
being stupid oh here we go okay
tractor huh rear view mirror
is that the last thing that he needs is
that value of zero
that might be that looks like that might
be it all right so i needed to go
i believe in here
oh pigs
hang on before i do that let me make
sure those cables didn't go anywhere
their power because i
i have a funny feeling i'm gonna have to
hit people yeah
you know yep that's that's the way
uh the cookie crumbles see looks like
uh it's shoveling time
hi bud hey pal
hi don't come any closer uh you know i i
need to
oh god oh i hate that whatever you have
no no no
oh god three oh pig
sorry okay oh my god i i was not
prepared
i was not prepared i was not prepared
[Music]
god sorry
sorry i feel bad
okay well oh well sorry pitchfork huh
that sounds
promising well i don't want this shovel
to break i'm just worried about it
actually breaking i don't know if they
just go red or if they actually break
hi pig sorry about that don't
oh no this might have been a mistake
this might have been a horrible mistake
okay wire that's uh great yeah um can
you
take um you hold on to
ah why frick oh my god
you freaking oh my god you
do oh my god okay i'm gonna go around
you
are you mad cause i hit you i didn't
mean to look i literally did not mean to
okay i don't i i literally am
only here oh my god oh
no oh no oh no
oh no oh no
oh
it's not regular me looks very rotten oh
why did i come in here there's got to be
like a generator or something
ah oh no no no no no no no
no why do i need the generator was there
a generator even here did i even need to
come in here
i have no idea i literally i am so
i have meat this is a meat mistake the
great meat mistake and i've i've wasted
time but at least i have
a rear-view mirror i did see it in an
item and i just didn't know about it so
i can go over to puerto ric
and i can give him this and then i can
go back to my base and i can try again
tomorrow because
holy crap trick i really want to see the
ship of yours blast off
that'll be a sight to see that'll be
something special you know
i believe in you i had to kill someone
to see a pig a horrible
horrible pig really terrible pig
there you go advanced information
display yay
finally i have everything i need go your
way now
go please i need to install these parts
in my beautiful rocket and then
off i go i will wave to you when i'm on
my way to where no man has been before
okay thank you i had to drop some items
what did i get a welder
oh welder is wait
oh i need that to upgrade my workbench
okay all right the mission parameters
have uh have changed um i need
to get back to my base so i can
re-upgrade my
workbench survive another night and then
uh you know
you know let me do my you know what
actually i'm not
i'm gonna open my third eye at night
because i'm very curious as
to what i'm gonna see god damn it i
gotta stay another night here
that's fine that means i moved my labs
for good reason
good good reason okay upgrade workshop
yes
upgrade yes yes yes next
up is axe an exploding barrel holy crap
i can make armor light armor
that's neat do i just need to have it in
my inventory
do i have to put it on what do i need to
do for that i don't know
i need to repair my shovel i've got a
pitchfork but i'm not exactly
looking i guess maybe i could do
something about it do i want to do
something about it
increase weapon durability is it
something that i really want to do
something about
i don't know enough to make that
judgment i'll use it for tonight
but i i don't know is it a good weapon
no idea two weapon parts holy crap let
me just
test it out so i can it's pretty good
it's not bad better materials eight
eight
scrap metal oh my god you know what's
the only thing i can upgrade
let's let's just go for it you know why
not right okay 1650.
i guess i can explore a little more um
have i really explored the area to the
right of me
have i done that i don't know oh i have
not there's a whole
truck whoa
and a tire weird this was just here the
whole time and i never bothered to look
to the right
what is going on here what is happening
oh that's what's okay that's that's a
problem
oh that's a problem you know what let's
this is a problem for this is why i have
a gun
where are
there we you that's why i have a gun
that's just why that is why is there
anything in there
worth ah there was all right more gas
more weapon parts that's good a tool box
it was right here the whole time
shockingly steering wheel i don't need
anymore higher i guess i don't really
need any more either
weapon parts get rid of that for now i
can come back for that
okay um wow that was just by my house
the whole time
just there if this night is uneventful
which i hope it is
we'll be speeding on our way to our next
destination
which is the next safe house well we'll
be just
taking a little bit of our time with it
just slow and steady you know
real slow and steady i've got the armor
i
do i do i like have to oh it has to be
ah okay well that's okay i can take that
that's fine and i need
bear trap i mean i'm gonna take a gamble
on the door
i don't have enough for both that's why
i got a gun
okay night has begun so in some time in
the night i'm gonna
open up my third eye just to see
everything once things start to go crazy
but other than that i'm expecting a very
uneventful night
okay i'm gonna open up my third eye
oh god of course it only lets me see
what's in the room
i thought it was for some reason i
thought it was going to reveal the
entire
eclipsing area i'm an idiot i'm an
idiot okay so far so good
my third eye really helped there
ah i bet correctly
oh oh that's big stip stomps
that's big stip stomps that's really big
stip stomps
that's really big stip stomps oh no
okay hello well come on in come on in
hey what's up
oh no
oh this doesn't do as much damage as i
would have hoped
okay doesn't have anything close it
barricade it before whatever the big
stip stomps were
becomes a problem yeah that wasn't
nearly as much
uh damage as i would have hoped i'm
going to
get rid of that now that is not good for
me
shovel it is trusty shovel
all right all right all right all right
d11
okay hey bud how you doing again it's me
same place for some reason i don't know
why
either i need to upgrade next pliers
probably some quest is gonna give me
that
i don't know if i'm gonna need these
weapon parts
definitely but i've got three of them
now so i think
military flashlight i i don't know how
useful that is
probably extremely probably
exceptionally but for now
i don't know can i scrap metal you do
you have that that and then
that except i want the shovel blade uh
for now let's see what that because i i
want to be able to make the upgrade for
the shovel
to make it super shovel upgrade item
upgrade
light materials better sturdy blade i
need
better materials eight eight scrap metal
you know it's the only thing i can
upgrade let's just go for it
i am a man who owns
five lock picks five okay for now i'll
leave that there
i'll leave the shovel blade in there in
the metal pipe let's see what else we
can buy
i should have just gone for the axe
blade i don't know why it's
stupid but you know i'll i'll save it
till later
all right we're gonna venture off again
this time really gonna get there
nothing's gonna get in our way now i
don't know what the whole pig pen power
situation is
but uh i didn't wanna mess with the big
pig i think the big pig is fine
doing her job just the way
that it should be time to mosey
let's do it all right see you around bud
i still don't know what all the roots
are only at home
there's got to be some meaning to that
like the you look away and roots are
just
covering every part of it that has to
mean something okay
straight across straight up through the
mite patch and then shoot my way across
a bridge and make my way to the old
woods hideout
that's how we do that's how we do see
you in the old woods buddy
all right let's do it
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa oh my
god oh my god i forgot how to
deal with you oh my god
god damn it damn it damn it damn it oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god i can't see you where are you
there you are oh god
you suck every encounter is like
life for death until i get good enough
in the game that i feel like i can
competently handle everything
every encounter is life or death i can't
take anything for granted
and i can take nothing lightly bear
traps
i would love some yeah well ah not again
not again
oh freak you no god damn it
where are you stop
okay here we are
done why don't these stack i don't know
why they stack i'm not gonna eat them
that's for damn sure whoa hello
mushrooms
okay here's the pig pen area no what is
this
oh the generator's right there well i
did not do that the generator's right in
the oh
god i'm so stupid oh my god of course
oh hey oh sorry didn't realize you were
oh sorry um
hey bud you have a savage in your house
uh that's you should probably take care
of that before you try to take care of
me
sorry lady
uh sir sorry sir um anyway do you have
any gas i didn't bring gas because i'm
an idiot
and my armor's gone apparently i hope
you have gas in your generator here
please talk mirror mirror talk i don't
know if i want this
do i want this
you are one ugly bastard i guess you got
what you deserved
wow that's the first time i've seen
myself
there i am not as much as a freak as i
thought i'd be
still a freak nonetheless okay
generators on
various cables protrude some of them run
through the door there's a lever
red button motion range of levers
limited by professionally attached plate
read the note set the voltage using the
lever the lock is set to a voltage that
paralyzes the sow for a moment
what procedure the lever operator
positions it in the middle the feeder
gives a sound signal
the operator then pushes the button and
the feeder feeds the sow repeat until
the feeding is complete
remember the sow is our common good do
not remove
the lock oh no so 15 seconds is not
enough time to get
to the place where the where the mother
pig is so put the lever to the middle
that would get it for 15 seconds but
that's not enough time
that would not be enough time to go
unless there's a way in here no no
god this is gonna eat up my time again
i'm gonna have to stay another night but
is this worth it oh my god i like need
someone to help me but i killed all the
people
ugh all right you know what i'm here i
came this far
let's kill this pig position the lever
all the way down
push the button
oh kill the p oh i killed the pig
apparently good great
i was hoping to do that i was hoping i
was really crossing my fingers
on that one anyways that pig's still
angry at me you still mad at me
you still met yeah oh you still mad at
me oh he's still made
there's some goodies in there but i'll
i'll leave him just because i don't know
what goodies are awaiting me
on the corpse of this pig
hey you uh you dead you you dead
oh you did all right oh
wait did i not get anything for this did
i do this for nothing
did i do this for my own satisfaction
did i oh
it's time for my piggies to go to bed
the great big mother piggy has said so i
will count them first to see if all my
piggies come back to me
one little piggy two little piggies
three little piggies
81 81 i don't know if that's important
great i am so glad i am
so glad i did this i am just
so happy i am so gosh darn happy
that i did this yahoo
let me check one more time because like
was that it was it was that it
i don't want the odd meat i don't want
it
i don't want the odd meat i really don't
want it
or doesn't even be black from the other
side well you know
it is what it is god am i headed back to
my house for oh my god
was there there was someone that talked
to me about the pig earlier there was
someone that said something to me about
the pig who was it was it violin
violin boy was the violin boy do i have
to go talk to oh you know what
he's still playing there so there's got
to be a reason for that right i want to
go back to violin man
i might have to survive one more night
here i want to go to the new hideout but
i don't want to miss
out on something there had to be a
reason for me killing that
pig rabbit
so i wonder how the hell to get into
these things the rabbit pushing that
couch is that rabbit really
oh no you shoulda shoulda tried ah
you got away ah that's okay
let's go say hi i've been avoiding him
but you know it's all okay
you know we all make mistakes and i
don't even know if i made a mistake
hi the boy oh
[Music]
the boy stops playing and lowers his
head avoiding my sight show item plastic
suit it's so pretty could i hold it for
a wee moment
i'm like sees would you buy if i were
big and had the
money i would buy more of these maybe
she would stop being angry at me
gossip i saw the villagers dragging a
cart with a dead south they
one they called the mother of all pigs
it wasn't as beautiful as they said
nowhere near the pretty lady
and that piggy it was a bit similar to
me the villagers have been crying after
her a lot
i saw them trying to cut through the
wall of trees do you think it's even
possible sir
mommy told me once that the woods are
never rev-ending and there's nothing on
the other side
i'm making a mad dash i'm going for it
i'm going for the next place
okay wait no let me think this through
think the action through think what i'm
about to do through
i have effectively six hours to get
there
board it up i can do that
i've got all the time in the world i'm
committing i'm committing to this
i'm committing to the journey the
journey is happening i wish i had eggs
or bread
bread or eggs bregs but it's okay
i'm committing i like the commitment the
commitment is good
strong leadership is what it's all about
bold initiatives
they won't see it coming i'll catch them
by surprise it'll almost be too easy
they'll be expecting me tomorrow little
do they know
i had a sneak attack in store i go in
front of them to go behind them
and sneak up on them and then they're
dead
wire perfect exactly what i needed
everything's falling into plan
like i said almost too easy almost to
the bridge already
barely even an hour has passed by
oh god no oh boy here we go here we go
here we go
okay i don't have time for your meat i
just needed to kill you
oh my shovel that's okay that's why i
got a gun almost too easy
i'll line up my board just in case let's
do this
this is almost too easy where am i oh my
god it's so easy
and i see the path ahead i'm ready
oh god oh god oh god oh my god i got it
yo i'm gonna activate that running power
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna bolt down
i'm just gonna
book it i'm just gonna book it
is actually what i'm gonna do i'm just
gonna book
i'm gonna book it and i'm booking it oh
i'm
booking it wait no god i'm booking it
oh god i'm booking it would you believe
let me open up my
third eye for a moment
good job lost him i don't even see him
in my third eyes periph
so silly wait was that did i just see
oh i thought i saw a shiny stone or
something i don't know why i would
bother i don't have enough
anything to do that did i get enough
wood did i bring enough wood with me
oh god oh god oh god okay the church
apparently
it's all good it's all good it's all
good it's all good almost there almost
there almost there
something going on there okay found a
weird tree location perfect
perfect is this it is this it please
tell me this is it i didn't bring gas
oh my god i didn't bring gas oh my god
please tell me there's gas in here
oh my god i forgot
oh no don't touch those oh no
oh no oh no okay there's the work bench
there's a wardrobe let me see if there's
anything in oh a welder that would
whoa whoa wait
yeah okay um oh my god
i am ins i am so oh gasps put these away
put that in there it's fine
don't touch them where's the stupid
there's the oven
okay like the oven the oven is lit once
again
yeah put the mushrooms in there no sit
up
okay uh wait no no
rubber rubber i don't destroy destroy
gender destroy destroyed this
wait why no wait a minute
wait stop hold on stop
destroy generator oh my god oh my oh oh
my
oh my god what can i repair okay i can't
repair it okay
um uh uh
um uh
[Music]
uh
i'll make a lantern i'll make a lantern
i'll make torches i'll i could i can
make this work i can make this work
i just need to be my own light source i
need to be my own guide i need to let
the light that's shining inside of me
shine
from within and make it shine outwards
that's what i need
so let me put this stuff away real quick
uh quick as a flash quick as a flash
uh lantern what do i need i don't have
what i need that's okay
i'll use the bell something's happening
of course something's happening
almost too easy why don't they make this
a challenge for me oh hey bud
how you doing good to see you how you
doing
alcoholic ah good vintage bring your
junk from the other hideout
which hideout from the silent forest
on it like a fox in a trash can all
right let me barricade this
how long does it take him to get the
package my goodness there's a lot of uh
exposed surfaces huh okay
really making this easy on me really
making it easy on me tell me there's
something in here huh
no fuel in here already that would be
too
easy didn't i grab fuel did i put fuel
away
oh my god why would i do that no all
these doors are just wide open huh
okay okay okay it's fine it's fine it's
fine i
need this uh it's fine it's fine it's
fine it's fine it's fine i need
more uh
oh my god fuel oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god that's enough okay
give me that give me that okay oh my god
oh my god
oh my god i'm n there's no way there's
there is no way
oh there's no way oh god there's another
window oh my god
okay um oh i can't even make a torch
i have flares i have flares you know
what i need to i'm
trying to do the whole place i obviously
am not gonna be able to do the whole
place up
so i just need to focus on where the
exposed places are
that window's barricaded this door needs
to be barricaded and then i can stay
in here yes yes come on oh my god
hurry this is uh the no good
this is um this ain't good
oh okay i guess i don't have enough of
that and my shovel's broken
okay i might have enough time to go fix
my shovel can i
at least repair my shovel
yes i can that's what i can do and i did
that
i don't have enough for anything else i
can go cook
these mushies that's what i can do
i'm gonna die
oh flares oh mushy oh oh i didn't even
see that
because it was dark you know
whoa that was a lot of mushies okay
chuck this in here okay good oh it's
like a lupity loop
so i have the light the door is
barricaded the only other place that's
not barricaded
is that door right there so what i'm
going to do
is i'm going to drag this one to block
up one of these
at no to i'm gonna move
i i don't know what i'm doing
i don't know how long flares last i
really don't
okay that's it that's how long
this is why i have the flares oh good
bugs
that's a lot of bugs has a exorbitant
amount of bugs
okay bugs are gone well that's good
everything seems to be okay oh no no no
no no no no
[Music]
everything seems to be fine it's fine
it's all good
dad me squeaking that legitimately
almost killed me maybe because i'm in a
new place the savages don't know where i
am yet i'm gonna go with that yeah the
savages don't know where i am yet
okay i'm gonna switch to torch okay now
shockingly
i guess you don't need the generator but
with
not getting here and the generator being
destroyed really
really upset me quite a bit that's not
okay but thank goodness relatively
uneventful hey if not and if i hadn't
stepped on that one mushroom i would
have had a new upgrade
new superpowers yay
day 12. torch one now perfect timing
hey bud what do you like the new duds
huh
pretty cool right visibly struggling
that whoa
the man drops the sack from his back and
bends in half as if out of breath
he shakes the gusts off his clothes and
rolls up his sleeve of his seemingly too
small jacket i see some new words
written on his forearm
the forest wants to devour you you're
heading straight into its jaws
well you didn't have to come out here
man i would have worried if you weren't
out here but
god i don't want to put you in danger
that's the last thing i want to do okay
so
uh this one's been going on way too long
obviously you've seen a cut down version
but i've been recording for like an hour
and a half now but this game is so fun i
love it
i love it i have no idea what this new
area is going to do for me but
i can't wait to see so thank you
everybody so much for watching
let me know what you think down in the
comments below and as always
i will see you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]